In this lecture, we'll be
discussing the story of Netflix
and how their
recommendation system is
worth a million dollars.
Through this example,
we'll introduce
the method of clustering.
Netflix is an online DVD rental
and streaming video service.
Customers can receive
movie rentals by mail,
and they can also watch selected
movies and TV shows online.
Netflix has more than 40
million subscribers worldwide
and has an annual
revenue of $3.6 billion.
A key aspect of the
company is being
able to offer customers accurate
movie recommendations based
on a customer's own preferences
and viewing history.
From 2006 through 2009, Netflix
ran a contest asking the public
to submit algorithms to predict
user ratings for movies.
This algorithm would
be useful for Netflix
when making
recommendations to users.
Netflix provided a training data
set of about 100 million user
ratings and a test data set
of about three million user
ratings.
They offered a grand
prize of $1 million
to the team who could beat
Netflix's current algorithm,
called Cinematch,
by more than 10%
measured in terms of
root mean squared error.
Netflix believed that
their recommendation system
was so valuable that it
was worth a million dollars
to improve.
The contest had a few rules.
One with that if the grand
prize was not yet reached,
progress prizes of
$50,000 per year
would be awarded
for the best results
so far, as long as it was
at least a 1% improvement
over the previous year.
Another rule was that
teams must submit
their code and a
description of the algorithm
to be awarded any prizes.
And lastly, if a team met
the 10% improvement goal,
a last call would be
issued, and 30 days
would remain for all teams to
submit their best algorithm.
So what happened?
The contest went live
on October 2, 2006.
By October 8, only
six days later, a team
submitted an algorithm
that beat Cinematch.
A week later, on
October 15, there
were three teams
already submitting
algorithms beating Cinematch.
One of these solutions beat
Cinematch by more than 1%,
already qualifying
for a progress prize.
The contest was hugely
popular all over the world.
By June, 2007, over
20,000 teams had
registered from
over 150 countries.
The 2007 progress prize went
to a team called BellKor,
with an 8.43% improvement
over Cinematch.
The following year, several
teams from across the world
joined forces to improve
the accuracy even further.
In 2008, the progress prize
again went to team BellKor.
But this time, the
team included members
from the team
BigChaos in addition
to the original
members of BellKor.
This was the last progress prize
because another 1% improvement
would reach the grand
prize goal of 10%.
On June 26, 2009, the team
BellKor's Pragmatic Chaos,
composed of members from three
different original teams,
submitted a 10.05%
improvement over Cinematch,
signaling the last
call for the contest.
Other teams had 30 days
to submit algorithms
before the contest closed.
These 30 days were filled with
intense competition and even
more progress.
But before revealing
what happened,
let's investigate how we could
try to predict user ratings.
In the next video, we'll discuss
how recommendation systems
generally work.